大家好 我是Seyoung
大家好 我是Crystal
現在是
我們在宋宿的凱爾谷
我們今天最後要去吃香蕉
我們現在要去找我們另一個朋友了
現在這個大地光很漂亮耶
好冷喔 冷到我眼淚都掉下來了
但是其實今天蠻冷的 今天現在只有五度而已
然後我們兩個居然只穿了這樣
我裡面是一件香蕉套 然後再加一件就是
然後再加一件Martin King的皮外套
然後妳的呢?
我裡面就只有一件短袖
因為我現在沒有什麼衣服可以穿了
我這次來都把衣服穿完了
神經病
跟一件皮外
喔 滿涼的
五度的天氣她裡面穿短袖
神經病
沒辦法 這次沒買什麼東西
就叫妳買衣服了
叫她多買一點
她需要打扮自己
我們剛剛早上用了什麼?
泡泡的 很像MOOS的產品
對 然後它是一個
保養品的彩妝
那個形容詞是這樣的
昨天韓國歐膩跟我們說的
然後昨天他就跟我說
如果他說
사요? 保養品的彩妝
他沒有說你沒有彩妝
他真的覺得
我們昨天用的那個
摸光的那個保養品的美膏
真的滿好用的
因為早上起來上完妝
就是超級的透
我們剛到這間
昨天歐膩推薦給我們的一個
造物餐廳
然後它就是有東北的一些島嶼攤檯這樣
感覺蠻local的
現在開始今天的移動
안녕하세요
我們往那裡來了
的最後
最後的日子
大家先給我一張照片
謝謝
你好
我是Crystal
現在是KRISTA CHANNEL
這次的CHANNEL
這次的CHANNEL是
我拿走了
我把這個CHANNEL搶走了
從現在開始由我接管
呃
CHAEYOUNG
現在太忙了
吃KRISTA
差不多
你可以雙手伸直
然後再往後
多一點點
你的胸椎的旋轉的角度
可以再多一點點沒關係
嗯
有趣的有趣
請訂閱、按讚、分享唷
非常的酷
很像我在纽约看那种古根汉博物馆的感觉
蛮特别的
但是我觉得最特别还是人的互动
就是人的表演
人的表演有非常多种
所以你可以很细微的观察到
那你们现在听到的声音
应该就是那些人在就是唱歌的声音
好久没有来汉南洞了
然后我就发现最近有一些新出的店
然后这个是Rose Jenny同款的衣服
我有在小红书上面看到的
是新的耶
我的菜耶
這些滿辣的喔
這邊還有跟兩層樓
走比較收神風格為主的
漂亮
陽光折射進來的美
沒有穿過裙子
這誰啊
我覺得超適合妳的
超適合我是嗎
哇
好新穎喔
連我自己都覺得很新穎
首爾真的對我來說算是一個
非常轻松
然后非常方便的一个地方
可能会讲韩文
我觉得对我来说
还是差蛮多的
就是来首尔旅游
这件事情会让我觉得说
在语言上面会有一种
很有成就感觉的感觉
就比起如果去欧洲的话
要讲英文这件事情
对我来说比较困难
但是如果讲韩文的话
就会觉得方便蛮多的
这一间呢
就是汉南东新开的一间店
然后我也是第一次看到它
忘记是去年年底
还是今年开的
然後綜合了很多品牌的一間店這樣
Martin King到Dipang到其他的Rotary的牌子都有這樣
這間不錯蠻好看的
那個單身極地獄的金高恩的pick
然後就發現很多都是他的pick款欸
蠻酷的
我們晚上要去吃烤肉
但實在是太餓了
我等不到那個時候了
就先點了草年糕
然後魷魚
然後跟一個sundae協場
我要來試試看他家的豆卜雞
我是豆卜雞愛好者
超愛
哇 很好吃耶